what are the different ways to make
money as a musician
when we were kind of first getting
serious in in music we thought there's
really a lot of opportunity to do music
licensing and so we were really working
hard to try to get songs in TV shows and
and video games and other and other
things and so we had a song in one of
the Dance Dance Revolution games we had
a lot of songs on kind of mostly smaller
reality TV show kind of types of things
but there was some you know Revenue in
that world and I think as as with all
things that look look to fruitful uh
everybody kind of rushed into that space
and so that there was a decline in that
and so there's still opportunity in
licensing and we still do some licensing
of our music we have some music on stock
sites we have some music available for
licensing other ways and we do make some
Revenue that way a lot of my friends who
are musicians who are full-time
musicians they do session work so they
they get hired to come in and play on
recordings
they also many of them play in what's
called a general Business Band where
they are performing usually covers or
something else like that and they're
playing at like weddings or kind of
other events along those lines so those
are the the main areas I think original
music uh you know we have some revenue
from Spotify and now CD sales are
basically over with completely I don't
think even anybody really approaches
that too seriously anymore but there are
streaming services where we get some
Revenue we get revenue from plays on
YouTube Believe It or Not
um and so you know there are still some
some streams but I think as with film
anybody who is serious about music needs
to kind of diversify what they're doing
because you can't just say I'm gonna
play in a band write songs sell CDs tour
and make enough money that's a that's a
really rare thing and even bands that
are I I see articles almost every day
about bands that you would think are
quite successful
saying that going on tour just is not
viable for them they're not going to be
able to break even on touring especially
with gas prices and other other kind of
inflation issues right now so
and what about the whole like well we'll
sell merchandise Theory yeah I don't I
don't think I mean you can make money on
that certainly we we used to sell uh
shirts and and other things like that
um but yeah I don't think the revenue
streams are strong enough to really make
a living that way I know that that was
the argument when streaming was first
coming out that yeah you lost your your
uh record sales revenue but you'll just
make it up in touring and in merch and
other things like that I I just don't
think that's true for 99.9
um of of musicians now most musicians
this is this is also something to think
about
um there's that sort of argument but
most musicians also didn't make a living
selling CDs you know in the 90s even in
like sort of the Heyday of of the
highest prices for physical media and
for for selling albums and where you
know many many albums were going
Platinum there were big sales in in the
music industry
um most people that that uh I I've met
and talked to who played in bands at
that time even bands that were
moderately successful bands on MTV and
such weren't really making a great
living or we're only making a living for
maybe you know a year period or a two
year period before it kind of went bust
so
as in all Arts uh it's
whatever amount of money you think
anybody is making doing whatever they're
doing they probably are making less
money
at what point should a film maker expect
to make money from their movies
that's a really hard question to answer
I think uh
I I've come around if you had asked me
this a few years ago I would have said
you know you should take some time make
the best art you know worry about the
money later but I've come around to
where you have to take it if you want to
be able to do it sustainably unless
you're just you know wealthy and you
don't care about it if you want to do it
sustainably as a career or you want to
be able to continue making movies in a
reasonable fashion you have to really
think about making money I think almost
as soon as you're starting to make
serious films and I'd say you know if
you're just doing shorts so some people
start out doing shorts uh doing
festivals with shorts as kind of calling
cards and I would say not to expect to
make money doing shorts I don't think
there's really uh much of a viable
income stream for that though maybe you
know some a little bit but once you
start making features I think you have
to immediately think like this needs to
be monetized to the degree at least to
the degree to which I can continue
making films and to which I can
demonstrate that the films I make are
breaking even or profit because that's
what's going to make
people in the industry want to you know
hire you or work with you or give you
money to make something else so I think
even just to sustain any any kind of
career you have to place that as an
important factor
and also too putting yourself in a
position where you won't be straddled
with so much debt right that's
definitely a big a big issue uh I think
you know with
any filmmaking uh you know most Indie
stuff most most kind of starter stuff
it's filmmakers paying out of pocket or
the family or you know somebody kind of
paying for it and uh it it really is a
big burden if you're if you're taking
debt to do it you can't make more films
I mean you can't continue making films
you have to find a way to to raise that
it's very stressful it it takes away it
takes years off your life uh and that's
you know that's not I I don't want that
happening to people I want them to find
a way to kind of be able to do it
sustainably sure so living below your
means it's also part of like whole
lifestyle in some ways right yeah
definitely I mean you know you have to
find a way to to budget your life uh
such that you can create what you want
to create and we have a lot of friends
who are filmmakers who uh they're
they're waiting for their you know
million dollars to show up to make their
first feature film because they think
this is the film I want to make I need a
million dollars to make it I'm just
gonna keep asking people until they till
they give it to me and we be taking the
opposite approach where we say well
what's the most amount of money we can
scrape together reasonably and uh you
know uncomfortably or the most debt we
can take on reasonably and comfortably
and then what is the thing that we can
make with that amount of money and uh
and we make that and then we move on to
the next movie you know it's not it's
not about stopping there and saying this
is we're done we've made our Great
Masterpiece and I worry the people who
are waiting for that money will be
disappointed when you know they get
their if they get their million dollars
and they make their film if it's not
their career doesn't explode you know
what what do they do next you know wait
wait around for the next opportunity
like that I I don't know
and it's also a form of continuing
education
because you're getting better with each
one or you're learning okay that didn't
work let's never do that again or that
did work right absolutely I always say
that we we try to make new mistakes with
every film you know we try not to make
the same mistakes we always we always
find new mistakes to make and uh and
yeah every every time
um it's an opportunity to explore
something new to learn from what you've
done before to try something different
and to be more skilled at what it is you
do hopefully you're getting better I
mean not maybe not every filmmaker is
getting better with with each film but
you would hope that if you're paying
attention to what you're doing you're
paying attention to the response and I
am a believer a lot of a lot of artists
want to create and then just say I'm
going to ignore the audience I'm just
making what I want to make I don't care
what anybody says or how they respond to
it
I'm a Believer in always paying
attention to what that response is and
to paying attention to what kind of
feedback you get now
a lot of that can be feedback for
different reasons there are many trolls
out there things along those lines so
you have to learn how to disregard the
kind of meaningless stuff but when you
hear 50 people saying the same thing you
say okay it
they're not wrong you know I must be
wrong it's not it's not the 50 people
who are wrong and it's an opportunity to
to get better at especially writing or
crafting or structuring or editing
that's something that we've definitely
learned from our first film to our you
know to our most current and there's
still many many probably another you
know 20 films of growth ahead something
like that
how much easier is it to make money as
an artist today as it was let's say 15
20 years ago well I think in film uh it
was probably if you if you were you know
making something that was watchable or
sort of serious it maybe took more money
going in but I think that there were
more opportunities in the marketplace to
make that money back or make some money
there there were bigger uh a general
movie that got a release made more money
15 years ago than it does today and when
I look at data because I see data for
for indie films right now and I mean
it's it's like mind-blowing how little
money a high percentage of films make I
mean
most of them make almost no money almost
none I'm not even talking about not
breaking even on their budget I'm saying
they make
less than a few thousand dollars in
Revenue so
um I think you know it's it's very very
difficult now to
make a lot of money unless you have
kind of the connections to the bigger
sales streams or you're making a sale to
to a an outlet that's gonna just pay
outright if you're trying to do it at a
consumer level like in the past you
might have sold DVDs that was a you know
big big Marketplace of 10 15 years ago
probably 20 years ago at this point
um
now you you just don't have that a
consumer who wants to watch your movie
is going to watch it streaming on Amazon
you're going to be paid one cent for
that that consumer if they had bought
your DVD you know you might have made
five dollars on that previously so I
think it's much much harder to actually
make a big sum of money uh than it was
15 or 10 20 years ago
and both you and Sophia made a decision
to no longer have Blu-rays or DVDs made
at some point we
don't do them ourselves so we we uh or
we don't sign Blu-ray deals that are uh
kind of typical uh label deals and we
don't manufacture them ourselves and
sell them but we have done certain uh
kind of limited run types of things
there's a there as an example there is a
great company called horror pack that is
a subscription service so every month uh
people who subscribe to it get four uh
Blu-rays or DVDs depending on which
package they subscribe to and it's a you
know surprise they don't know what's
going to be in the box but one of those
every month is a special limited edition
it's a kind of an indie film that horror
pack is uh doing working with the
artists to release the film on Blu-ray
and these are all films that would never
get a Blu-ray release otherwise and
um you know we've done that a couple of
times because it's it's a it's a
guaranteed Revenue so they basically say
we're gonna make you know X number of
copies we're going to pay you some
amount of money per copy and you know to
do anything else we're just sending them
you don't have to sell them you don't
have to convince people that we're just
going to send it out to our subscribers
and those people are who are
enthusiastic horror fans so it's great
those are the people you want you know
you want your movie in their hands
um it just gets sent out to them and you
just get paid so that's that hasn't
worked out well but there are fewer and
fewer of those types of opportunities
because there is still is probably a
small audience that does want those
physical uh you know media as a
collector's item or whatever right yeah
and there are a lot of Boutique labels
that are doing kind of Blu-rays uh I
think they're all abandoning DVDs at
this point but they um they put out you
know special packaging for Blu-rays and
they have kind of a rabid fan base where
there's a few thousand people who go and
buy you know very expensive actually
sometimes packaging for uh strange you
know strange releases and old releases
and Restorations and things and so there
is there's definitely a fan base for
that and collectors who who want those
kind of want to look at their wall in
their house and see sometimes they don't
even unwrap the movies you know they
just want to see it see him on the wall
there
um but I think a general movie consuming
audience is less and less interested in
in physical media I have a quote from
you no one really knows what's going on
in the world of film anymore concerning
selling a movie
I think it's true um you know it's
interesting because I I uh I'm in a lot
of sort of Facebook groups and other
kind of community groups and you see
people talking about some somebody will
come in and ask a question like you know
what how do I do this type of
distribution or how do I deal with this
and you see there's 20 different answers
and what's interesting is not just that
there are 20 different answers it's
looking at who the people are who are
giving those answers because if you see
somebody who's been in the industry for
a long time they're still giving advice
from like 20 25 years ago and you see
stuff you're like none of this applies I
mean I've been dealing with this you
know this year none of what they're
saying applies at all anymore
um we always say you know if we're
looking for advice on a Distribution
Company or a distribution Outlet or a
revenue stream from a streamer we always
say like if it's information older than
six months ago
just disregard it because that's how
fast things are changing so
you can't even it you know even if you
think you know what what you're doing
you think you know how to sell a movie
you think you know where the money Lies
by the time you make the movie
things have changed it's all over for a
short period we were actually making
enough revenue on Amazon for example
they were paying 15 cents an hour for
streaming on Prime and we were making
enough revenue from that that we said
look if we make another two movies that
are kind of doing as well as this one
movie we had was doing we're we're set
like we can we can survive just you know
making movies at this level we can pay
for the movies we can make enough money
to live on
um and then you know we started thinking
like we have this whole business plan
it's all going to be great and uh like
two months later Amazon's like we're 15
cents no we're gonna make it six cents
an hour I'm like okay that's maybe we
can still make something work and then
six months later it was one cent an hour
um so you can't rely on anything you
can't you can't make any any plans based
on what the current state of the market
is because it is such a rapidly changing
thing and and um
a lot of times the people who are you
know if they made a movie a few years
ago they really think they're like my
movie was successful I sold it to
Netflix I did this thing and it's great
but they don't even understand like how
those deals have changed that you know
maybe Netflix is no longer really buying
independent content they're only
producing their own content
um we make most of our Revenue now on 2B
for example an avod but I fully expect
that you know six months from now you
know maybe somebody watching this will
will have already experienced this but
you know a few months from now 2B will
have dropped all the indie films and
will only be doing Studio films or some
something along those lines so I never
rely on anything anything I think is
working I never I'm going to rely on
that for the future
did that happen with Amazon as well
where they stopped taking certain Indie
titles yeah they dropped a lot of titles
as well they changed their whole kind of
business model or idea of what what uh
Prime video was because for a while
Prime video was kind of a repository of
every you know they sort of thought like
well let's just put every movie on here
allow anybody to put a movie on here and
let the consumers kind of decide what
they want to watch and if they watch it
then you know the revenue goes up if
they don't
it's not there
but now they're very selective about
Independent films especially and they
don't accept many films for Prime it's
actually quite hard to get a film on
Prime
um which is funny because it pays so
badly that he you almost don't
I mean for from my perspective I almost
don't even care if her film is on Prime
because I don't really want that poor
Revenue I'd Rather somebody watches it
somewhere else and we get some some kind
of revenue from it what about IMDb TV
can you make more money off of that than
Amazon Prime yeah so I think IMDb TV I
think they changed the name to is it
freebie now I believe the name has
changed to free V and it is like a a 2B
style thing and I think they're they're
viewing it is like this is what we used
to do with prime where we're going to
accept more material uh it's going to be
ad based so the revenue is uh avod so um
there's an opportunity that if you know
your film is being watched you can
actually get get paid reasonably well
um I I think we only have one film on uh
on that service right now and I don't
think I've actually seen revenue from it
yet I don't think we've it's been long
enough to see revenue from it yet so I'm
not sure of the numbers but from what
I've heard it is actually a uh you know
has a promising future